this could be the last catch of crab to
make it out of jersey
the sarah p has been fishing the
guernsey waters for the last eight days
now the priority is to get it to san
marlo and into the eu
before france blocked ports and toughens
checks
it's very very worrying because if they
do close the inspection post down in
somali
we're completely stopped we won't be
able to buy anymore first we won't be
able to export until it's sorted out
we haven't got the option of shipping
through the uk and going out through
holland or going direct to spain the
logistics of it just don't work for us
it's just too far too long too long a
time and it doesn't work
this is jersey's biggest crab and
lobster exporter if they're prevented
from landing their catch in france
there's no point in jersey's fishermen
heading out to sea
the majority of jersey's catch is
exported to the eu so the closure of
ports and extra checks isn't just an
inconvenience it could stop the industry
overnight
the rao centers around licenses and
there are still 55 french boats on
jersey's red list meaning they'll have
no right to fish here from monday
we have
no hint
whatsoever that the boats on the red
list deserve a license in jersey no hint
we've never seen them we've never
no boarded them
nobody
no
jersey fisherman has ever seen them
they have no paperwork they have no data
from their gps's
we now have zero
hint that they've been in the area
they're trying their luck
they're trying dollars
tensions escalated after france seized a
scottish scallop trawler on thursday and
charged its captain
it led to the french ambassador being
summoned to the foreign office on friday
with france threatening to impose
restrictions from tuesday there is
little time to resolve the issue
many of jersey's fishermen are fed up
with the political fighting nobody's
going to win there will be no winners
there will only be losers
but will the french get more licenses
probably just because they're french
the uk says it will respond if france
carries out its threats
neither side is backing down
as this diplomatic storm in the channel
continues
dan whitehead sky news
jersey